this is DC councilwoman Brienne Nadu and  she is very upset because now DC is  being overrun by the very people that  she wanted to come into the country as  long as they were going to stay in Texas  the governors of Texas and Arizona have  created this crisis  and the federal government has not  stepped up to assist the District of  Columbia  we've learned from border towns like El  Paso and Brownsville and in many ways  the governors of Texas and Arizona have  turned us into a Border Town I mean  liberal logic it basically makes people  stupid are you stupid or something no  she's very upset and why is she upset  because DC is becoming a Border Town  what's the matter with border towns or  is for some reason she's okay with  border towns as long as they're in Texas  hey Patrick what am I now oh stupid no  I'm Texas what's the difference